hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Walking Dead finale video we
got to talk about all-out war season 8
stuff so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything and there's a new round of
the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video it was a crazy finale but I
did feel like the first half hour could
have just been rapidly sped up and we
would spend more time with that big
payoff at the end with Shiva rolling in
rolling in like a boss so they were
relatively faithful to the comics they
overlapped a little bit with the
beginning of volume 20 all-out war most
of this season was marched to war but
they really stretched it out and they
swapped out like the big comic book
death so I'll explain that as we go
through top 10 WTF and Easter eggs
number 10 Sasha's coffin so they keep
jumping back and forth between her
listening to that song which is
basically narrating what's going on in
her head everything's going to be great
everything will be fine this is the way
it's meant to go down she keeps jumping
back to Abraham which it seems like
actually happened in the past before the
events of the season five finale when
they took off and everything went to
[ __ ] when they ran into negan's men and
Abraham and Glenn ended up dying so if
you're confused about what was happening
in here yet she's hallucinating this but
it's a memory that she had before they
rolled out like she's saying don't go I
had this dream about you dying so she's
talking about a dream kind of within a
dream but technically at the memory and
you sort of get the set up that negan
wants to use her as bait to try and get
the survivors to turn over their weapons
number nine though Dwight has a plan so
this is all comic book stuff the white
wants to turn on negan wants to see him
dead there was a nice callback at the
end of the episode where he tries to
apologize to Daryl in a way he loved
that little chess piece as a way to tell
Daryl I didn't know that you were going
to be betrayed by the Garbage Pail Kids
I didn't know that sasha was going to
kill herself so it was a nice arc for
both of their characters they have a
very special relationship because at the
beginning of the episode he wants to
stab his face off and then he says even
after it's all said and done no matter
what Dwight does it's not going to be
over between them so obviously they're
setting up a Redemption are for Dwight's
character it's right out of the comics
if you want you can actually read ahead
if you don't care about spoilers but
it's going to be a big thing next season
in because daryl is not a comic book
character it'll be fun to see how he
reacts to that number eight he'll talk
the kingdom in the
Garbage Pail Kids all roll out totally
loved Ezekiel in this episode
I love his cheer for the glory of
victory like he tries to get Morgan to
not throw his life away he has that
barrier set up with the shopping carts
like he's planning on taking on any
saviors that come by himself so he's
like come come with us don't throw your
life away so I was so happy that Morgan
showed up at the end of the episode if
he's going to have to go out he wanted
to go out in a blaze of glory you don't
want him to go out by himself but
Ezekiel is one of those characters whose
art got changed big time during march to
war he already has an alliance with
hilltop setup rick is the one who's
still broken in Ezekiel has to talk him
into it so that's how their Alliance
comes together so on the TV show they
just made Rick the person to go around
and convince Ezekiel to join up so
comicbook Ezekiel is just a little more
hardcore but the end of the episode
pretty much like the last ten minutes of
the episode was right off of the page of
the comic book so even though they
changed the way they got there they
still did the same payoff that they did
in the comics number seven Garbage Pail
Kids revolt I think a lot of people were
expecting this just because Jadis was so
shady there was that funny moment with
Rick like they tried to ease the tension
a little bit hey when you're done with
him I can I could totally take a turn
Rick slowly backs away but the important
thing to remember about them is even
though they're scum they're complete
garbage as their name implies they
betrayed the survivors so what's to say
that they wouldn't also betray negan
given the opportunity there was this
moment at the end of the episode where
Jadis is like you promised us 12 and
negan's like nope 10 I'm not going to
give you the full terms of the agreement
and she stands there looking at it for a
minute you just wonder what's going on
in her head so she might be making plans
to double-cross negan in the future so
there's always a chance the Garbage Pail
Kids could flip sides again because by
Dwight's explanation first they had to
take care of the sanctuary then they had
to get more people and then go after the
satellite stations so talk about hanging
thread the one big thing they didn't pay
off this season is Heath I don't know if
they forgot about him or if they're just
waiting till season 8 but the key card
is a very big thing that's part of the
satellite stations so even if they were
able to take the sanctuary down that
wouldn't be the end of the Savior's
they'd have to go around to all the
satellite stations so that's just like a
big season 8 thing they have to deal
with but number 6 Sasha says her last
goodbyes
to Abraham I love the speech he gave her
it was like the last moment before they
open the coffin up for the big reveal
where he's like look you know you want
to stay behind but you're a good person
we put ourselves on the line for other
people for Maggie because she's carrying
the future so that's sort of the same
thing that Rick and Michonne were
talking about like look if I die if you
die it doesn't matter it's not for us
it's for everyone else it's for the
future they're basically talking about
Karl and all the young people they're
going to be the ones to enter the
promised land
the funny thing about that though is
that Robert Kirkman says if there's no
end in sight for the Walking Dead comic
so you almost wonder if they're ever
actually going to get to that future
it's like this mythical endpoint that
the show is never going to get to the
comics are never going to get to so it's
just kind of funny even though they're
making this new world they're trying to
lay their lives on the line so number
five we get the Sasha reveal she took
the pill comes out of Walker and it's
the Holly death from the comics or at
least a version of it so the changes is
that negan actually knew that she was a
walker and was going to use her as a
weapon against the Savior's but on the
TV show negan didn't know anything about
that so it was a slight twist on the
person in the way it went down but she
is able to do some crazy damage we will
miss her so much Sasha was a great
character towards the end she got pretty
badass in the last couple of seasons but
if you didn't know she's actually going
on Star Trek discovery she's going to be
a main cast member so last year when
they made the casting announcement most
of us were like hey wait a minute isn't
this a spoiler for her on the TV show
she's not going to be able to do both of
them so that might mean that she's dead
so there were a lot of questions after
we found out she was going to be on Star
Trek and now we have our answer she is
definitely dead and even though I feel
like they didn't need all that buildup
the final moment with Maggie like where
she is crying and she kneels down
that's her finding Walker Sasha who's
still active in finishing her off you
can kind of hear the knife come out of
her sheet but you will be missed
Sasha rest in peace say hi to Abraham
for us number four [ __ ] goes down
Michonne versus the garbage woman
hardcore fight this is like a version of
the fight that Rick had with the
governor back during season four the
last fight that he had where he got his
face all bloodied up to a pulp and he
basically looked like he was wearing a
mask
that's what Michonne looked like after
that all I could think about was post
Governor Rick but that line that she had
was so pointed where the one
who live so that was a callback to
something she said in a previous episode
brutal victory nothing let's you'd
expect from Michonne it would have been
better if it was Jadis just because of
the way she was creeping up on Rick and
the way she betrayed them but maybe
she'll get an opportunity during season
eight but number 3 just as negan is
swinging lucille down to kill Carl
Ezekiel Sheba the kingdom hilltop roll
in like a boss and everything explodes
and I think we can all say that we would
have rather had an entire episode of
this rather than all the build-up for
the first 30 minutes but the twist is
good I felt like they could have got
there a little bit faster even the
speech that negan gave about what he was
going to do and Rick's like you can take
my hand which was a total comic book
moment but the one thing that tipped my
hat to like okay maybe this might not
happen is when he said that he was going
to kill Carl because even if you feel
like Chandler Riggs is going to leave
the show because he's supposedly going
to university I don't think they would
kill him off they'd still find a way to
bring him back like it'd almost be
unforgivable given the people that they
killed at the end of last season or the
beginning of the season I should say but
number two negan and a handful of the
Savior's return I love the way they get
the intro walking by that safety sign
101 days without an accident so they're
going to change that recently negan
pretends like he's going to kill Eugene
and then you get the big wide pan out
we're going to war so also right off of
the page of the comics and it also kind
of reminds you of Attack of the Clones
when the Emperor's watching all the
clone troopers just roll out like look
at the size of this army this is going
to be crazy so they want to make it feel
like it's insurmountable for the
survivors even with their alliance that
they have the number one that final
eulogy for Sasha is Maggie giving her
that speech so if you didn't know what
this is from if you remember a couple
seasons ago I think it was season five
they were actually watching the Sun Rise
just sort of reflecting on their lives
it was just meant to be this nice moment
within just thinking about all the stuff
they've been through where they were
headed next the choices they had made in
Maggie actually said something really
important where she talks about how
Glenn made a choice to help someone out
and it's a big deep cut for the pilot
episode the very first episode of The
Walking Dead she says it started with
the two of you he chose to help you out
she's referring to the time that Rick
got stuck in the tank and Glenn radioed
him to help him out
hey you dumbass yeah you and the
Thank You cozy in there thank you
dumbass
and you want to tank so that's their way
of invoking Glenn in their philosophy
for how they help people so you know
some people are walking dead turn and
betray other people like Eugene betray
them some people choose to help other
people and it's sort of a metaphor for
what's happening right now but they use
that moment with Glenn to tell that
story and sort of make you cry thinking
about his life so let me know what you
guys thought of the episode obviously
we're going to start with all-out war
and if you want to read ahead just start
with volume 20 all-out war the beginning
of that is actually this moment right
here so like the last five minutes of
the episode is the beginning of the
all-out war comic book so we can all
guess about how long they're going to
spend in all-out war it's a huge event
there's actually like two big parts to
it so for sure if they stretched out
volume 19 March to war the group's
coming together as much as they did
during season seven just think about how
much time they're going to spend during
all-out war but there's way more action
as the name implies it's all-out war so
I feel like they won't have as many
problems with filler episodes they'll be
more action but you guys can let me know
what kind of videos you want me to do
because if everybody's going to bail on
The Walking Dead there's no point of me
doing weekly videos but if you do want
me to do specific videos for big comic
book events or characters I'm totally
happy to do that too but what will
happen is in a couple days I'll do a
predictions video for season 8 and then
we can kind of figure out how to do
Walking Dead bonus videos in the time
between till it premieres again in the
fall but there's still a lot of really
cool stuff left to happen we still have
the whispers that we haven't met yet
there are a couple other groups so
congratulations to the new giveaway
winner young dreams please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there's new Batman there's new flash
comic book stuff I'll try to do my
predictions video for season 8 as soon
as possible so while you guys wait for
that you can click here for all my other
Walking Dead videos and you can click
here for brand new Rick and Morty thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video